[Music]
arthur blank
the owner of the atlanta falcons bought
the team
nearly 20 years ago issued a statement
the only statement that came from
anyone with the falcons organization
regarding
the guy that they traded up in round one
ten years ago to get one of the great
players in the history of the franchise
there's a statement there we also have
the full text of the pft
chris i thought it was interesting
that there was no statement from gm
terry fontenot
or from head coach arthur smith just
something perfunctory
fonteno's been with the saints i i know
firsthand
the difficulty that julio jones
creates for an opposing team
yada yada yada yada period arthur smith
my former team the titans is getting a
great competitor we've studied him we've
competed with him but yeah
something perfunctory that just is like
hey
here we go i i think that it wasn't an
accident that both guys were silent and
this
gets to the point that we were talking
about earlier why we didn't see the
falcons
make an overt effort to try to trade
julio jones until the monday of draft
week remember the monday of draft week
that's when three different reporters
all had the same thing
what a coincidence no it wasn't the
falcons pulled the court on the
lawnmower to try to get
something lined up for julio jones it
would have been effective june 2. and
you're right chris
if they would have started this back in
late february early march
maybe somebody would have said hey uh
okay
fine we can wait until june 2. i mean
look at what the giants paid kenny
gallaudet yeah do you think if the
giants could have gotten julio jones
instead of kenny holliday they may have
thought maybe this is better for us
all due respect to the gallaudet right i
mean if we're concerned about hamstring
injuries
crap the golidae had worse of a
hamstring problem last year
than julio jones missed more games than
julio jones last year
so i agree with you they could have
gotten that first round pick if they had
started sooner here's what i believe
here's what i believe based upon what i
know and now what i think
yeah i think they were trying to work it
out with him
and one of the things i'm told is he
just would not engage with the new head
coach
no taking calls no responding to text
messages and
you know i they understand the value of
having julio jones on the team
and i think they didn't work their way
through the anger denial bargaining
depression and acceptance until
right before the draft where it's like
hey guys we gotta we gotta have a plan
here what's our plan
okay our plan is let's start trying to
find a trade partner now
effective june 2 and they came to that
conclusion right before the monday of
draft week
before that i think they were holding
out hope that they could make it all
work and who knows what they would have
done with the fourth overall pick
if they thought they were keeping julio
jones around but i think that's why
they didn't move any sooner because they
they were
they were hopeful they could find a way
to mend the fence
and they finally woke up right before
the week of the draft
and said we just can't we got to move on
yeah maybe
you know maybe maybe that's what it is
if that is the case though
you know it's it's just you know not a
great job in reading the tea leaves of
the situation i'll say that much
i mean yes because you know again they
pigeonholed themselves a little bit yeah
free agency was over
oh we're gonna hope i hope we can work
this out i hope i hope i hope i hope
you know that again i think at some
point maybe early on there you just got
to pull the cord and go
wait we're new there's something he
doesn't like here he
wants he doesn't want to be a part of
this new change in a place he's been at
a long time so he's looking for a total
change
and that's where you just got to rip the
band-aid off and and do something
tough there so if that's the way it went
down hey then you
certainly can still blame atlanta in
that situation for maybe not being a
little more aggressive earlier on and
then
in this situation but they're stuck and
i
i understand them not putting out a
comment mike i do just to
reference that real quick they have no
relationship with them and like you just
said
there's been no real conversations or
contact
and they probably feel a little bit you
know disrespected to a degree
not that they're going to take it real
personal because it's not personal but
at the end of the day they're human
beings they're going wait we got here
and now he says he doesn't want to be
here so and we never got a chance to
really sell ourselves to him
so that's probably why we don't hear a
quote from them either well i just know
from experience that when there's a big
transaction like this the press releases
yeah
from everyone you're right something
right one line
it is rare right rare pr writes it the
coach looks at it and says
okay or otherwise grunts and that's the
the statement that's put out on his
behalf happens all the time
i think in this case they were
deliberately omitted from the process
because he didn't engage with the new
regime
and arthur blank had to had to say
something somebody had to say something
so it was blank
and look let's not understate the
influence of blank on all of this and
one of the reasons why maybe they didn't
do it soon
that's right blank wanted that first
round pick one of that first round pick
and you know you got to figure out how
to properly
navigate life with a billionaire
who can fire you at any moment not not
that he's just
walking around arbitrarily firing people
like russell dalrymple backstage at the
seinfeld pilot but i know it gets more
and more obscure every year but
i i i think that they had to convince
arthur blank
to stand down from his expectation that
he was getting a first-round pick
and it took him a while to do it and
eventually he did blink and
you know i wrote that story yesterday
and it's like oh yeah you know
anytime anytime you give a little poke
to a billionaire you never know what the
blowback's going to be but it's the
truth
he blinked and this deal wasn't getting
done until he blinked unless they were
going to follow a strategy chris like
the one that we had
discussed last week where you find a way
to hold julio jones
until somebody gets into the season and
somebody gets intoxicated by
their super bowl potential and somebody
says then fine we'll give you a first
round pick
for this guy because we think we're
going to be drafting low in round one
anyway yeah well that's where the risk
was though right that's where i can't
fault them for making this trade right
now because yeah
doing what you're talking about
certainly like would have given them the
best chance to maybe maximize what you
can get for julio jones when it all said
and done
but i mean also yeah i don't know
somebody falls on his leg and he breaks
his ankle in week one
but he doesn't show up or doesn't show
up what if they haven't
got you got you got you where where
where they work out of dealer he stays
away and they just put him on ice but
but the thing is who's going to pay him
that people are going to be
not feel comfortable right yes right
there's going to be an uncomfortable
aspect there they were stuck
as far as the situation is right now and
mike like i think your point there is
very real
and i wish i would have brought that up
like the for the point of
maybe why they weren't aggressive
earlier on in free agencies
see these things i don't know i haven't
heard enough rumors here or things in
the in the know yet
to know but maybe that fonteno and
arthur smith were
going to be aggressive early on in free
agency maybe arthur blank was the one
that said wait i think i could smooth
this over and make it work
so maybe they wait for him you know
those are the dynamics we don't know
that's why i certainly don't want to
blame anybody
and that's why i say yeah it doesn't
look great but i think for the situation
it is right now i think atlanta did as
good as they could have done
you're talking about a new gm yeah a new
head coach
an owner who's had the team 20 years and
your guy rich mckay the guy who drafted
you
in 2003 yeah he was the gm of the
buccaneers as kind of the liaison and
that's a name
that that never gets mentioned in this
but i guarantee you rich mckay
had a huge influence on how this went
down because he's the one
i believe who would be going to arthur
blank to have these
these delicate conversations about
when and if they need to abandon
their insistence on getting a
first-round pick
for julio jones and you know from the
titans perspective chris i thought of
this last segment
and maybe this is one of the arguments
that the falcons made to try to get a
first round pick number one it is gonna
be a low first round pick most likely so
it's basically a second round pick so
just give us your first round pick oh
and by the way
you wasted a first round pick last year
on isaiah wilson
i i wonder how much the the wilson
experience
was a factor in trade talks and how much
it contributed
to tennessee's decision to say
hey these are all craps yeah we don't
know firsthand with isaiah wilson
why not send as torrey smith pointed out
a draft pick for a proven commodity
because
you always take the proven commodity
over the unscratched lottery ticket
yes i mean there's no doubt about it you
do and
maybe maybe it did it certainly did i
mean
john robinson's really smart i don't
want to say it certainly did but i think
it just goes back to the old adage of
like
okay wait yeah there's a little bit of
injury history he's a little older
but he's julio jones and we know what he
is and how great he is
and everything he can bring to the table
as compared to you know like you're
saying a crap shoot
there for for julio jones you know just
all of it all of it's good for
for the tennessee titans that's where i
look at it
other than they just got to figure out
some cap things and
yeah you're gonna have to maybe pay him
some big money
if he has a big year or something like
that but that's probably a problem they
welcome as well
i i mean that that's what they're hoping
for here but i just think some of the
moves they made in free agency
and now like julio goes to a place where
you know it's just a better setup for
him all together
in every aspect the team's better i
believe
ryan tannehill's better than matt ryan
and he's a better down the field thrower
so that's going to benefit julio and
unlike in
atlanta where there's no run game to
speak
of right now or anything like that i
think even statistically
this place is better for julio to then
you know make more money and do all that
so everything makes sense from julio's
standpoint
and other than the contract situation to
me everything makes sense from the
tennessee titans standpoint as well
i i i made the remark
privately on saturday that we were
officially at the point in the julio
jones life cycle where there was nothing
further to report
when someone from espn reported that
julio jones wants
a guy with a big arm who can throw the
ball down the field gee thank you
thank you for that yes i thought he
wanted a guy with a pop gun arm chris
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports